the Joe Rogan experience have you ever
tried down no hello I don't know why
he's guilty
God yeah yeah I have not tried heroin
have you tried cocaine yes how dare you
I have getting coked up mm streets you
hooked up right around anymore
how kind what happened because you don't
know what that shit's cut with anymore
that's true and that dabble I saw some
video and they're like that'll do it one
more time and it'll kill you I'm like
nope fentanyl yeah well I had a guy in
here who's the guy's name Ben was it Ben
West Hoff the writer who fentanyl wrote
a book on fentanyl he used to be a he
was a journalist he used to write for LA
Weekly then west on ranked yes
fentanyl Inc and he said they were
reviewing all these raves where people
were dying and like they're dying from
MDMA and like it didn't make any sense
so they did some tests they found it's
not really fentanyl or it's not really
MDMA they're dying from it's MDMA cut
with fentanyl yeah and plus they're not
hydrating themselves because that you
sweat because those people what it is
they'll just rave until their heart
explodes it's probably some of that -
yeah it's probably a few of those but a
lot of it it's just overdoses offense
you know because they're cutting it no
trust drugs anymore that's why drugs
should be legal you know that's one of
the mayor Pete things he had this weird
conversation with one of the journalists
were there he was talking about
decriminalizing drugs and the guy was
like would you so you would say heroin
would be legal and he goes no wouldn't
be legal he goes well that's what
decriminalizing is like this is weird
conversation where they're trying to
work out the legal logistics of what's
decriminalized and what's not but it
sounds totally counterproductive that if
you wanted to have a healthy happy
Society you'd make cocaine and heroin
legal right but the problem is if it's
not legal then people are gonna get it
anyway and they're gonna get it from the
[ __ ] cartels and you're gonna get it
it's gonna be spiked
I don't want anybody to do heroin I
don't want anybody do coke I don't want
anybody to do any of these drugs but the
only way you're gonna give them pure
versions of that drug is to make sure
that it's actually from a reputable
source
mmm
reputable yeah I was a reputable it's a
weird way of saying it tomato tomahto no
I'm terrible I've done I was like weird
people let's say nucular nucular nucular
nuclear nucular that i've done ice that
was one things ice so I think it's math
yeah how was that good times I fall how
long stay awake oh all night
[ __ ] I was like I think I was 22 and
like a friend of mine at the time I
guess it was like hey we're gonna smoke
this out of a light bulb I'm like I
don't know why how do you smoke it out
of a light you're just it's like a it's
like the end of it was cut off and you
just light it underneath it's like a
hole one cut a like I don't [ __ ] know
I like I oh man I did that and I just
remember going to a bar and just talking
the [ __ ] bartender's ear off just
non-stop
I remember going home and then I
remember being like 3 o'clock in the
morning I'm like you know what sounds
good I'm gonna move all my furniture
around it was just like my neighbors
were probably like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then I remember going to bed finally
at like 6 o'clock in the morning and it
was the worst feeling I've ever
experienced in my life like my body just
felt broken rotted
oh yeah just just corroded
yeah energy is coming out of somewhere
well because the price once you do it
you're addicted so it was like really I
was yeah it's like right when it ended
is when my body was like you need more
you're going through withdrawals so I
wouldn't I was one time one time that's
all it takes
really mm-hmm and then I I literally sat
in my room and just shook it all out and
sweated and I remember making a vow to
myself I was like I am never doing this
again in two and then finally it was
like someone asked me they're like have
you ever I was like yeah I'd never done
math I mean I've done ice and they're
like that's what that is you dumb [ __ ]
it was like oh man I mean
it was not not pleasant and you see how
quickly people can become addicted to
that one time once you're addicted all
it takes
Wow so at the end of it you're like oh
my god I'm so wrecked I just need a
little to get me over and then next
thing you know you're doing a little all
the time
[Applause]